bueno la respuesta estaba esperada para
las seis de la tarde llegó unos
minuticos antes de las seis algunos
periodistas pudieron entrar para recibir
de primera mano la decisión del Consejo
constitucional y pues ya se sabe que fue
aprobada en su mayoría aquí enfrente del
Consejo constitucional hay muchísimos
periodistas de muchas nacionalidades
hasta gente es que también estaba aquí
esperando la respuesta entonces pues ya
se sabe que la edad de jubilación a los
64 años está mantenida la reforma la más
polémica de de esta reforma también se
sabe que el referéndum que había sido
propuesto por la oposición no ha sido
aprobado Entonces no habrá referéndum al
parecer y también algunos puntos fueron
retocados los que son sobre los adultos
mayores lo que se había previsto por los
expertos en derecho constitucional ya
que se sentía venir estos dos puntos
en este momento pues vamos a ver lo que
pasa sabemos que hay marchas en
desarrollo en una ciudad de tulus por
ejemplo hay otra en París de estudiantes
que estaba prevista llegar hasta aquí
ahora que la decisión salió vamos a ver
lo que va a pasar sin Margot usted con
estos a detalles que nos daba no se da
luz verde finalmente a este referendo no
que era una de las esperanzas del
movimiento social para derogar esta ley
y también se aprueba el aumento de la
edad de jubilación de los 62 a los 64
años sin duda esta decisión no va a ser
muy bien recibida por los movimientos
sociales que ya estaban a la expectativa
Total no antes lo comentábamos cuáles
eran un poco los dispositivos ahí frente
al consejo constitucional de Cara a este
fallo y a las posibles reacciones que
pudiera haber en las calles
pues vamos a ver lo que va a pasar el
barrio del Consejo constitucional está
completamente cerrado Hay muchísimas
policías justo al lado mío está la
comedy José es que es uno de los teatros
más famosos de París ya cancelaron todos
sus funciones para esta noche un poquito
antes de las seis a las cuatro de la
tarde Emmanuel anunció que se iba a
reunir con los interlocutores sociales
el próximo martes ahora tenemos que
estamos a la espera de saber que van a
decidir esos interlocutores sociales que
van a que van a qué dirección van a dar
al movimiento social ya sabemos que la
cgt y efo quieren mantener la
contestación cuál sea la decisión del
Consejo pues ya la tenemos la cfdt ya
había anunciado que se iban a reunir la
semana entrante para tomar la decisión
un miedo que existe dentro de esos
interlocutores sociales es que se divide
el movimiento ahora que pues se ha
anunciado esta decisión y que quizás no
todos estén en la misma página